اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
حرب اوكرانيا وتجنب وقوع حرب بين القوى
الكبرى تهيمنه على مناقشات قمه العشرين في
بالي
انفجارات والقوات الروسيه تتراجع في لوجان
اضراب يا عمو مدن ايران في ذكرى معي
احتجاجات عام 2019
وتسريب لمسؤول يكشف عن مزيد من التشدد ضد
المحتاجين
وفي ملفات الخامسه ايضا عدد سكان العالم
يتخطى 8 مليارات فرصه للاحتفال امن الفزع
اذا مشاهدينا تتواصل في جزيره بال
الاندونيسيه قمه مجموعه العشرين بمشاركه
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وقاده ورؤساء دول المجموعه مسوده بيان قمه
العشرين اعتبرت ان استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه والتهديد بها غير مقبولين جاء في
مسوده بيان القمه ان معظم الاعضاء يدينون
وبشد الحرب في اوكرانيا وتدعو هذه المسوده
الى ضروره تمديد صفقه الحبوب الاوكرانيه
المسوده اضافه ان المجموعات تبدي انشغالها
بتاثير الحرف في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد
العالمي وخلال افتتاح القمه ضد الرئيس
الاندونيسي جوكو ودودو قاده المجموعه على
انهاء الحرب وتجنب حرب اخرى بين القوى
الكبرى
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بدا لقاءاته مع الهامش طبعا هذه القمه مع
قاده العالم حيث استقبله اولا الرئيس
الاندلسي جوكو ودودو الامير محمد بن سلمان
التقى ايضا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وذلك على هامش قمه ال 20 منعقده حاليا في
بالي
وايضا على هامش هذه القمه التقى ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان برئيسه
وزراء بريطانيا ريشه سوناك وعبر سوناك عن
امل بلاده مواصله العمل مع السعوديه من
اجل استقرار اسواق الطاقه هناك ولي العهد
السعودي اعرابا قلقهما تجاه التهديدات
بالمنطقه بما فيها سلوك ايران
وكما استعرض ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان للعلاقات الثنائيه وعدد من
الموضوعات ذات الاهتمام المشترك مع رئيس
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد
بن زايد
هذا وقد استعرض عدد من قاده مجموعه
العشرين ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه ادعوا طرفي
الازمه الى وقتها حتى لا تتوسع عالميا وفي
هذا الاطار اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسيس
ارجيله بروف انه منع تسييس البيان الختامي
لقمه العشرين مشددا على ان بلاده جاهزه
للتفاوض لكن اوكرانيا هي التي ترفض
التواصل الاتفاق وذلك لان الدول الغربيه
تامر
الرئيسكي بعدم الدخول في مفاوضات مع موسكو
لان الولايات المتحده ومن خريطاني في
الحرب باوكرانيا طبعا كل هذا على حد
تعبيره ظروف قال ان اتهامه روسيا بالعدوان
على اوكرانيا استفزاز مقصود لكن في ذات
الوقت اشار الى ان هناك الكثير من الدول
لم تنضم للعقوبات ضد روسيا مضيفا ايضا ان
عمليه روسيا العسكريه في اوكرانيا مشروعه
لكن الرئيس جلنسكي لا يريد السلام
كما تعمل بروفا الغرب محاوله تاسيس
الاعلان المشترك لقمه العشرين لادانه
روسيا كما ذكرنا نستمع اليه
بالانابه عن جميع دول مجموعه 20 بالرغم من
ان الموضوع خارج جدول اعمال المجموعه نعم
هناك حرب في اوكرانيا الغرب بدائها وكان
يحضر لها منذ سنوات وان كان يحاول القاء
اللون على روسيا بسبب فشله في التوصل الى
اتفاق المشترك بشان اعلان مجموعه العشرين
هذا يعني ان الغرب لم ينجح
والمزيد معنا من جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه
العربيه الى هناك ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك
نادي استمعنا الى الابراج يتحدث عن تسيي-
تيسيس البيان الختامي لدينا نقاط رئيسيه
حول المسوده هل نتوقع اي تغيير ام كما هو
اهلا بك ميسون لن اتوقع تغيير في الواقع
على سالت المسؤول امريكي قبل قليل مرافق
للوفده الصحفي هنا
ذكرت بالتحديد هذا هذه المسوده واذا كان
هناك بالفعل ادانا واضحه لروسيا قال لي
بانه همم بشكل عام المجتمع الدولي باكمله
اذان الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده وبالتالي
الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى تكرير ذلك
بهذا المعنى هي تقول بانه اثار وتبعيات
الحرب الاوكرانيه على روسيا همم ادت همم
عفوا همم الروسيه على اوكرانيا ادت الى
هشاشه الاقتصاد العالمي بالنهايه مجموعه
الدول العشرين هي تمثل اكبر اقتصاديات
العالم واكثرها متانه واكثرها تاثيرا في
الجيو السياسيه وبالتالي اعتقد بانه من
هنا جاء الاسرار الامريكي اولا على دعوه
الرئيس
لينسكي لمخاطبه القمه وايضا على اشارات
على ان تاثير هذه الحرب كارثه ليس فقط على
اوكرانيا لكن على الاقتصاد العالمي على
اسعار النفط على الامن الغذائي وعلى اسعار
همم الطاقه والمحروقات بشكل عام فاعتقد ان
لن نرى هذا لكن هناك تغير اقصد لكن اعتقد
ايضا ميسون بان هناك اجماع على خطر
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه سواء كانت تهديد
من كوريا الشماليه او تحديد من روسيا وهذا
امر واضح طبعا سمعنا من رئيس بعد لقائه مع
الشيشه بينك بالامس الذي قال بان هناك
اتفاق على عدم استخدام هذه الاسلحه طيب
فيما يتعلق بلقاءات الجانبيه ناديه اهمها
وبالمقابل ماذا نتوقع ايضا
اولا هناك لقاءات ثنائيه جمعت رئيس مع
رئيس شيشبنج طبعا ولاول مره يلتقيان وجه
لوجه رغم انه يعرفه في السابق لكن هي كانت
هناك الكثير من المؤشرات الايجابيه التي
ادت ايضا الى الاستمرار في فتحه القنوات
كما قال لي البيت الابيض وايفاد وزير
الخارجيه في بدايه العام القادم طبعا الى
بكين ايضا اجتمع مع رئيس التركي همم
اردوغان هنا طبعا ادانا عمليه تفجير في
اسطنبول وتحدث ايضا على الامن الغذائي
وعلى تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
وساطه تركيا في ذلك همم ايضا سيلتقي مع
همم ريتشي سوناك وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
غدا والتقى مع رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا هذا
بالجانب الامريكي طبعا قبل قليل الرئيس
اعتذر عن المشاركه في حفله العشاء البيت
الابيض قال بانه مرهق بسبب الاجتماعات
الطويله همم لكن ايضا سيكون له يعني لهذه
القمه غدا بالنسبه
لمحمد بن سلمان صحيح
الامير محمد بن سلمان
وهي فرصه ليس فقط ايضا للمشاركه بحجم
السعوديه وبتقلها الجغرافي والاقتصادي
والمال والديني لكن ايضا هي فرصه لتعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه يعني لقيت همم لاحظنا
هذا الاهتمام من الرئيس الفرنسي مثلا
الرئيس مكروه الذي اقترب من الامير وهمم
سلم عليه وطبعا لم يكن هناك لقاء ثنائيا
لكن همم تعرفين بان هذه اللقاءات عاده حتى
لو كانت في دهاليز هذه القمه هي مهمه
لقاده العالم لتبادل بعض النقاط التي هي
نقاط تحدي لكل موجودين هناك
مع رئيس دوله الامارات وايضا مع رئيس
التركي هل من انجازات سجلت لهذه القمه حتى
هذه اللحظه
نعم الكثير من الانجازات ميسون طبعا هي
قمه اقتصاديه بدرجه الاولى رغم ان الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه القت بظلالها على هذه
القمه لكن قبل قليل الرئيس بعد ان كان
يتحدث عن استثمار بشراكه مع بل الى جانب
الاتحاد الاوروبي واندونيسيا طبعا ب 600
مليار دولار مبلغ مهول يعني ان نتحدث عن
طاقه نظيفه نتحدث عن تحويل الاندونيسيا من
اعتماد على النفط الصخري لتوليد الكهرباء
الى الطاقه الخضراء تتحدث عن هيكله الديون
لدول فقيره مثل تشاد مثلا نتحدث عن
الاستثمار الرقمي عن التغيير المناخي هناك
اجماع من دول العالم على ان هذه القمه يجب
ان تحضر الى قمه الهند 20 23 والوقت محدود
24 شهر غير كافي عندما تتحدث عن كل هذه
التحديات بما فيها التحدي الصحي كيف
للعالم بقياده مجموعه العشرين ان يواجه
وباء مثل وباء كرونه اذا حدث مستقبلا يجب
ان تكون هناك جوزيه عاليه
الى هناك ناديه البلبيسي شكرا جزيلا لك
وايضا جدد المستشار الالماني على ان افضل
طريقه لتعافي الاقتصاد العالمي هي انهاء
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا واشاره شولد
خلال جلسه لقمه العشرين بشان امن الغذاء
والطاقه الا ان الحرف في اوكرانيا لها
تداعيات وخيمه ويجب وقفها فورا
وقبل ذلك كان الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون قد دعى نظيره الصيني على هامش
القمه الى ضروره جلب روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات لايجاد حل الحرف في اوكرانيا
مؤكدا على انه يجب توحيد الجهود الدوليه
للاستجابه للازمات العالميه كحرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا ذكرت الرئاسه الفرنسيه انا
ماكرون داعشي الى ايصال رسائل الى الرئيس
الروسي لتجنب التصعيد والعوده بجديه الى
طاوله المفاوضات مشيرا الى ان العالم يمر
في مرحله من الاضطرابات والتحولات التي
تحتاج الى الانفتاح والتعاون
وكان الرئيس الاوكراني بلدي ميرزلت قد شدد
في كلمته الى القمه على ضروره انهاء الحرب
التي وصفها بالمدمر في بلاده كما اكد
زنسكي على ضروره تمديد العمل باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الذي ينتهي عمده السبت المقبل
زنسكي حذر من انه لا توجد اعذار لممارسه
الابتزاز النووي كما اسمائها مقترحا اليه
لتبادل جميع السجناء مع روسيا
اسامه
وقبل ان نكمل بالتصريحات القادمه الينا من
قمه العشرين نشير الى العواجل الان
معلومات وهذه هي ايضا صور اوليه تصلنا من
قلب العاصمه بغداد حيث
يتم الحديث عنه قد اندلع في احدى صالات
مطار بغداد وكاله الانباء العراقيه تتحدث
ان فرقه دفاع المدني تتحرك لاخماد هذا
الحريق وهو ااه تحديدا في صاله المغادره
في مطار بغداد اذا هذه هي الصور الاوليه
التي تاتينا من الحريق طبعا داخل صاله
المغادره في مطار بغداد
اذن هذه صور اوليه مشاهدينا تاتينا الان
لاندلاع حريق يبدو انه هائل
ومشاهده من خلال هذه الصوره داخل قاعه
وصلت المغادره في مطار بغداد الوكاله
الانباء العراقيه تتحدث عن توجه فرق
الدفاع المدني الى هناك لاخماد الحريق
قال جيهان انفنتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم الفيفا خلال مادبه غداء بحضور
قاده قمه العشرين قال ان الفيفا يدعو الى
ايقاف النار خلال فتره بطوله كاس العالم
في قطر مضيفا ان اوكرانيا ستستضيف
المونديال بشرى مع اسبانيا وايضا البرتغال
في العام 20 30
رشا هو سده
2018 واوكرانيا ستتقدم بملف مشترك مع
اسبانيا والبرتغال لنسخه 20 30 اناسدكم
جميعا للتفكير في وقف اطلاق نار مؤقت لمده
شهر واحد طوال فتره كاس العالم دعونا
ننتهز هذه الفرصه لفعل كل ما في وسعنا
للبدء في وضع حد لجميع النزاعات
تمسك بلاده بالعلاقات الثنائيه مع فرنسا
مؤكدا ان الدولتين يجب عليهما التمسك
بالاستقلال والانفتاح والتعاون في قضايا
عده كامن الغذاء وايضا الطاقه موضحا ان
زياده التواصل بينهما من شانه ان يعالج
التحديات الاخرى العالميه
اريد اريد
الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
بره ايه اللي يعلنوا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيطلق اليوم مهمه تدريب لخمسه عشر الف
جندي اوكرانيا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
التطورات الميدانيه للحرف في اوكرانيا
عمده كيف اعلن ان هجوما صاروخيا روسيا
استهدفا مبنيين سكنيين في العاصمه في
الاثناء
الاوكرانيه استعاده 14 قريه في المقاطعه
واضاف المسؤول ان الروس يواصلوننا حفر
القنادق
وتلغيم المنطقه حول الكره المحيطه بخط
المواجهه ويطردون سكان من منازلهم ليستقر
فيها المسلحه اما عن المدن الكبيره طبعا
فيقول بانها تواجه ازمه حيث لا توجد
اتصالات بحسب ما افاد المسؤول الاوكرانيا
هذا وبالمقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اسقاط مؤقت لارين نتحدث عن سو 25 ومروحيه
108 خلال المعارك في قريه بابلو باكا
وقالت موسكو ان حصيله قتل الجنود
الاوكرانيين بلغت 1400 جندي المتحدث باسمي
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اجور كنا شنكوف اكد
ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت على القريه في
دوناتسك وبشكل كامل
وفي هذا السياق افاده مسؤول غربي لوكاله
رويترز ان روسيا منخرطه الان في عمليه
دفاعيه في اوكرانيا بعد انسحابها من مدينه
خرسون الجنوبيه تعهد الرئيس بلد مارسلنسكي
باستعاده جميع اراضيها المحتله كما شدد
على ان المزاعم الروسيه حول انسحاب 30,000
جندي من المرجح ان تكون مبالغ فيها مقدرا
ان العدد اقرب الى 20 الفرد
المزيد معنا من دونيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخضر اهلا بك رائد اخر التطورات
الميدانيه تفضلوا
مساء الخير بالفعل هنا في منطقه تنباس
وخاصه في مقاطعه لوغانسكو ودانيتك تشتعل
المعارك والقذف المتبادل ما بين الطرفين
الاوكراني والروسي والقوات المواليه ايضا
لروسيا بالفعل القصف شديد وعنيف جدا خاصه
على اطراف مقاطعه دانياس القوات المواليه
لروسيا تشن هجمات وعمليات اقتحام على
مدينتي
شمال غرب المقاطعه بينما كانت قد سيطرت
على مدينه بعد ذلك ما يورسك القريبه من
مدينه باخمط في شمال المقاطعه همم لفتح خط
لامداد القوات العسكريه التي تقاتل على
اطراف
تقاتل هناك وتحاول دفع شيء الجيش
الاوكراني للخلف من اجل السيطره على هذه
المدينه في الشمال همم همم دانيت لكن
حقيقه المحور الجنوبي ايضا يشهد تطور حيث
سيطرت بالفعل القوات الروسيه على مدينه
بابلوبك او بلده بابلو في كما اسلفت وهي
في المحور الجنوبي والهدف هو الوصول الى
المدينه التاليه وهي اوكلادور هناك حديث
من الخبراء عن خطه الروسيه لتصليط يعني
الضوء على دمباسه محاوله السيطره على كامل
دم باص في دانيت بعد الانسحاب من خرصون من
الضفه الجنوبيه لنهار دينيرو في خرسان
والتمركز في الضفه الشماليه بالفعل هناك
تصريحات من مقاطعه زبرجه من حشد كبير
اوكراني من اجل التقدم والسيطره على
المنشاه النوويه في زبرج بالفعل همم
المعارك اكثر سخونه ميسون هنا في منطقه ما
تشهد المنطقه او المدينه هنا في ثانيه
وصول اعداد كبيره
وامدادات عسكريه بشريه تشهد الشوارع
والاسواق نحن شهود عيان على ذلك اعداد
كبيره من الجنود الروس وصلوا هناك احاديث
عن انهم انتقلوا من خرصون الى المحور
الشرقي وهنا يعني حديث عن عنا اعداد من
التعبئه الجزئيه قد بدات بالوصول للحرب
همم والمعارك في اطراف المقاطعه الثانيه
بالفعل ايضا اسلافتي بالقول عن لجانس
تستهدف القوات الاوكرانيه مقاطعه لوغانس
وتقوم بعده عمليات وتستخدم صواريخ تقول
الدفاع الروسيه بانها تصد هذه الهجمات
واسقطت او نحت 90 جنديا في هذا المحور
انا من دونيتك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر
شكرا جزيلا لك وا الى همم هذا الخبر او
مراسلنا يبدو معنا من اكياب مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل اهلا بك حذيفه انقل لنا المشهد
من عندك واخر المعلومات المتعلقه باستهداف
كيف من قبل الروس تفضل
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع مراسل
العربيه كان معنا من كيف مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل وكنا نريد الحديث عن اخر
المعلومات المتعلقه
باستهداف العاصمه كيف صواريخ روسيه نعود
اليه اذا ما تستنى لنا ذلك
مشاهدينا قبل ان نكمل الملف الاوكراني
نعود الى خبر العراق هو الذي نقلناه قبل
قليل ونشاهده بين الفتره والاخرى على
العواجل اذا هناك حريق في قاعه وصاله
المغادره في مطار بغداد الدولي معنا الان
مباشره من بغداد مراسل العربيه منتظر
الرشيد منتظر اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديك
نعم بالفعل الحريق اندلع ااا قبل ااا
دقائق من الان ااا رعت فرق على الاقصى الى
داخل المطار بغداد الاجراءات الامنيه حاله
دون وصولها بسرعه لكنها وصلت قبل دقائق من
الان الى المكان الذي شهد الحريق وهو احدى
صلاه المغادره وتحديدا صاله نينوى
كافتيريا موجوده هناك هي من اندلع فيها
الحريق الى الان همم لم تعرف الاسباب
الحقيقيه
الموجوده في صالات المغادره احدى صالات
المغادره وهي عديده داخل المطار بغداد
الدولي فرق الدفاع المدني
تمكنت من اخماد الحريق وصلت
نعم نعم
عن النيران تتصاعد اتخيل ان هذه الصور وقت
اندلاع الحريق ولكن الان هناك اعلان نعم
اللحظات من اخمال الحريق داخل احدى
الكافتيريات في احدى صالات المغادره في
مطار بغداد الدولي
وقامت ايضا فرق الدفاع المدني باسعاف
ثلاثه من العمال الذين اصيبوا بحالات
اختلاف نتيجه كثافه الدخان المتقاعد من
هذا الحريق اذا فرق الدفاع المدني تمكنت
من اخوان الحريق همم وهذا الخبر همم يعني
قبل دقيقه من الان تمكن من الانتهاء من
عمليه هذا الحريق اضافه الى ان همم تم
اخراج كل المسافرين طبعا الذين كانوا
يتواجدون في هذه الصاله والصالات القريبه
كاجراء ان احترافي لكن على ما يبدوا
الحريق محدود وليس همم
ما ذكرت الان تم اخماده وبالكامل همم قبل
دقيقه من الان تم الاعلان عن ذلك شكرا
جزيلا لك منتظر الرشيد على هذه المعلومات
وننتقل الان ونعود الى اوكرانيا حيث كشف
مفوضه شؤون الخارجيه والامن في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل كشف ان الاتحاد سيطلق
اليوم مهمه تدريب 15 الف جندي الاوكراني
واضاف بوريه القبيله اجتماعا للوزراء
خارجيه والدفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بروكسل ان قوه التدخل السريع الاوروبيه
ستكون جاهزه في عام 2025 كما اكد على
ضروره ان تعمل الدول الاوروبيه معا لتعويض
مخزونها العسكري بعد دعم اوكرانيا
طبعا ننتقل الان الى ايران وبينما تستمر
التظاهرات في ايران كشفت تسجيل صوتي مسرب
لمسؤول مخابرات ايراني ان النظام سيلجا في
الايام المقبله الى المزيد من التشدد ضد
المحتاجين المتحدث ذكر ان هناك مختلفه حول
كيف بدات الاحتجاجات موضحا ان وجهه نظر
واحده تشير الى ان هذه الاحتجاجات لم
يصنعها العذوبه كانت نتيجه الافعال السيئه
والمساوئ الداخليه في ما زعمت وجهات النظر
الاخرى انها من تخطيط العدو حسب رغم ان
المسؤول الاعتراف ايضا بان الكثير من قتل
الاحتجاجات ابرياء الا انه شدد على ضروره
التعامل بطريقه قصوى للسيطره على الازمه
وفق التسجيل الصوتي وبدورهم يخطط
المتظاهرون مع حلول الذكرى السنويه
الاحتجاجات 2019 لتصعيد الامور الى مستوى
جديد ليجعله من اليوم والغد وبعد غد من
نوفمبر الحالي جحيما على النظام الايراني
وفقا لجنه مبادره زغروث وفي سياق اخر طلب
الت- مجموعه شباب احياء طهران طلبوا
المواطنين بعدم دفع فواتير المياه
والكهرباء والغاز بما يشبه العصيان
المدنيه
في هذا السياق اعلن اصحاب المتاجر في
ايران عن اضراب عام في اغلب المدن
الايرانيه اغلقوا محلاتهم الى اجل غير
مسمن دعما للمظاهرات الحاليه وايضا احيانا
لذكرى قتل السلطات الايرانيه في عام 2019
لاكثر من 2000 متضاهر من بينهم نساء
واطفال وايضا رجال الشرطه دعنا نتابع
نار الاحتجاجاتي لا تخمد خناق يلف مدن
ايران ينتفضوا اهلها على باب رزقهم حتى
اغلاقات لا تردد فيها لاحياء ذكرى قتل
النظام الايراني للمتظاهرين عام 2019
اصحاب المحل التجاريه والباعه في اسواق
ايران يقولون كلمتهم اضطرابات عن العمل في
عده مدن ايرانيه دعما ايضا لمظاهرات خرجت
منذ شهرين لاسقاط النظام هكذا هو الحال
ملامح العصيان على اوجه المحلات في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه انضموا جميعهم الى دعوات
لمسيرات الاحتجاج العام لا شيء يوقفهم رغم
تهديدات النظام الايراني بتوسيع رقعه
الاعتقالات والاعدامات بين صفوف المحتاجين
كارثه وجوديه تواجه الشباب والقصر في
ايران بسبب الاعتقالات الاخيره بحسب وصف
صحيفه نيورك تايمز اكدت في تقريرها الاخير
عن اعتقاله ايران للمئات من المشاركين في
المظاهرات وقتل الكثيرين في حمله قمع
وحشيه تشنها السلطات واشارت الصحيفه الى
ان استهداف الشباب ياتي وسط حمله للمحتجين
تخللها اعتقاله 14 الف شخص اضافه الى
استهدافا للاطفال وقتلي 50 قاصرا على
الاقل حتى الان تهديد ووعيد من السلطات
الايرانيه بحده غير مسبوقه على مدى
العقدين الماضيين بحسب التقرير ايضا ما
ينظر بمستقبل انساني يشتد ضبابيه اكثر
فاكثر غذاء السالم العربيه
المزيد معنا من لندن الكاتب المختص في
الشان الايراني دكتور نبيل الحيدري اهلا
بك دكتور اسمح لي ان ابدا بالتسريبات التي
استمعنا الى بعض النقاط منها كيف تقراها
وتوقيت مثل هذه التسريبات من يمكن ان يكون
وراءها
تحياتي لك سيدتي ميسون عزام
ومشاهدي قناه العربيه الكوار طبعا نحن
اليوم نمر شهرين على هذه الثوره المباكه
ولذلك اليوم بدا اضراب عام ل اييي مختلف
المدن اشوات المدن هنا لكي اضراب من
بازازه طهران الى بازاو اصفهان الى يجد
الى
تبريز الى مشهد
وايضا ذكرى انتفاضه
2019 التي قتل فيها 1500 شهيد هذه
التسريبات طبعا هي همم هو مسؤول امني كبير
في وزاره المخابرات وزاره المخابرات هو
يتحدث مع واضح ان هؤلاء كلهم من وزاره
المخابرات وهو مسؤول امني كبير وفي يد
وهؤلاء كلهم يزديين
يتحدث عن حقائق يقول اولا هذه المساء مين
هي في الواقع يعني
ليس هنالك مؤامره فيها ولم تاتي من الخارج
انما تابعنا وسالنا كل حتى هذه الدوريه
التي اعتقلتها كان ما بيها شيء فاذا
الحادث منا وقال ان عدد القتلى اكثر من
15000 وبدا يتساءل اسئله كثيره
من 15000 شخص بس هو سرد اكثر من نظريه
فيما يتعلق بالرؤيه وتحدث عن عدوه عن من
نتحدث وبالمقابل اذا كما ذكر هناك شلل
تحليلي وصفه ب 2019 ماذا همم نصف ما حدث
الان بالنسبه لنظام الايراني
طبعا انا تذكرين قبل يومين انا قلت عددا
معتقلين 30,000 وذكرت ارقام طبعا ولكن انا
كنت انقل عنه ما قاله هو 15 الف هذا
التوقيت عشان هيك صححت لك صحيح صحيح
المعتقلون قال 15,000 نحن نعتقد اكثر من
ذلك بكثير نعم ما هو السؤال كنت اسالك
فيما يتعلق بتصريحاته انه هو يتحدث عن
اكثر من سيناريو ومن ضمن ان يكون هناك عدو
هو الذي همم يحرك الناس على الارض من
الخارج من هو هذا العدو وايضا في سياق
تصريحاته تحدث انه ب 2019 كنا نحيه هذه
الذكره كان هناك نوع من الشلل التحليلي
عند لدى النظام فكيف يمكن ان نصف الوضع
الان فيما يتعلق بما يحدث على الارض
بالضبط سيدتي ميسون هو ذكر ثلاثه احتمالات
اولا عدو خارجي وثانيا ان يكون داخلي
والاحتمال الثالث الذي رجعه هو الوسط انه
مثلا حدثت هكذا ولكن هنالك عدو خارجي ذكر
احتمالين احتمال ابن الشاه وذكر واحتمال
اشخاص من الداخل ومنهم قال الحسين موسوي
لقياده هذه المظاهرات وحسين الموسوي طبعا
من الخطا الاصلاحي 2009 في الثوره الخضراء
اعتقل هو وزوجته الى يومنا هذا
الان هذا هذا المسؤول همم من المخابرات
نحن نعرف انه هنالك اجهزه استخبارات عديده
يعني وهذا الصراع بينها هو الذي كشف ذلك
بحيث يخرج هكذا تسريب مهم فعد هنالك
استخبارات استخبارات للحوادث هذه
يسموها مينفعش وزاره الطلاعات يعني وزاره
المخابرات التابعه الى همم رئيس الجمهوريه
ولكن تلك مؤسسات اخرى
ولذلك انه همم
المتوقع يعني هذا التسريب وكشف هذه الامور
في تحليل هذه كيف بدات ومنحتها واتصالها
بالخارج والمستقبلها ويقول نحن لم نتوقع
لا هذا الجيل الجديد ولا هذه السعه فيها
ويبدا يحلل هذه
المظاهرات فاذا هذا تسريب مهم جدا ومن
داخل النظام نعم
مختص في الشان الايراني دكتور نبيل
الحيدري شكرا جزيلا لك
الخمسه ولكن بعد قليل
احباط ومحاوله ايران اغتيال رجل اعمال
اسرائيلي في جورجيا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامس
من المواد المتفجره كانت متجهه الى اليمن
الاسبوع الماضي في المياه الدوليه لخليج
عمان
الى شواطئ اليمنيه
بين اكياس الاسمده هذه خبيت اطنان من
المواد المتفجره مواجهه لميليشيات الحوت
في اليمن
القصه بدات يوم الثامن من نوفمبر في
المياه الدوليه لخليج عمان وعلى طول طريق
يستخدم تاريخيا لتهريب الاسلحه الى
الحوثيين اعترضت البحريه الامريكيه سفينه
صيد قادمه من ايران وافراد طاقمها
اليمنيين الاربعه اكثر من سبعين طنا من
وقود الصواريخ اثرت عليها البحريه
الامريكيه داخل قارب صيد لفتتهم وزنه
الثقيل بسبب الشحنه الكبيره من المتفجرات
كما عثر داخل القارب على مئه طن من سماد
اليوريا التي يمكن استخدامها في تصنيع
المتفجرات
ضخمه من المواد المتفجره تكفي لتزويد اكثر
من 10 صواريخ بالستيه متوسطه المدى
بالوقود حسب الحجم
قامت القوات الامريكيه باغراقه بعد تحديد
انه يشكل رن على الملاحه كما تم تسليم
الطاقه لخفر السواحل اليمني
للمساعدات القاتله من ايران لا يمر مرورا
الكرامه انه امر غير مسؤول وخطير ويؤدي
الى العنف وزعزعه الاستقرار في جميع انحاء
الشرق الاوسط
ت كذلك على ان اعمال التهريب التي تقوم
بها طهران خطيره وغير مسؤوله واكدت ان
التوريد المباشره او غير المباشر للاسلحه
او بيعها او تهريبها الى ميليشيات الحوثي
ينتهي فقرار مجلس الامن الدولي رقم
216 والقانون الدولي
عمليات وتهريب السلاح الايراني لمليشيات
الحوثي ليست بجديده بل وتسارعت في الاونه
الاخيره والامثله عديده ففي ديسمبر الماضي
ضبط الاسطول الامريكي الخامس شحنه بنادق
وذخيره في سفينه صيد قادمه من ايران كما
صادرت البحريه الامريكيه في يناير الماضي
40 طن من سماد اليوريا المتفجر على قارب
صيد ايراني كان في طريقه لامداد الحوثيين
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
اعلنت المخابرات الجورجيه انها احبطت
عمليه اغتيال من قبل ايران استهدفت رجل
اعمال اسرائيلي المخابرات قالت ان المنفذ
المعتقل الباكستاني الجنسيه بالاضافه الى
عدد اخر من الاشخاص ممن تعاونوا معه
لادخال السلاح
ارتفعت حصيله قتل حادثه الطعن في مستوطنه
اريال بالضفه الغربيه الى ثلاثه ذكرت
تقارير اسرائيليه ان قوات الامن اطلقت
النار على المنفذ في مكان الحادث بعد طعنه
حارس امن قرب مدخل المنطقه الصناعيه في
اريل وشخصين اخرين قرب محطه وقود
عدد سكان الارض خطى 8 مليارات فهل هي فرصه
للاحتفال ام للفزع بالنسبه للامين العام
للامم المتحده هذه العتبه تستحق الاحتفال
لانها ترمز للتنوع وايضا التطور ذكر
العالم
بمسؤوليته المشتركه تجاه الكوكب وعلى نفس
النمط الايجابي ارجعت الامم المتحده النمو
السكاني الى تطور البشريه اذا ان الناس
باتو يعمرون اكثر بفضل تحسن خدمات الصحه
العامه والتغذيه والنظافه الشخصيه
والادويه لكن من جهه اخرى فاقما النمو
السكناني التداعيات البيئيه الذي يقول
الخبراء ان نمو السكانيه السريع يقلل من
جودتي وكميات الموارد الطبيعيه من خلال
الزراعه المكثفه والتجزئه الاراضي وكذلك
لاستغلال والاستهلاك المفرط للمواد خاصه
من قبل الاشخاص الاكثر ثراءا ياتي ذلك في
الوقت الذي حذرت فيه منظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه التابعه المتحده الفاو من اثر
هذه الزياده السكانيه على فجوه الامن
الغذائيه قالت المنظمه ان تكاليف واردات
الغذاء في انحاء العالم تتجه صوبات تسجيل
ما يقرب من اثنين تريليون دولار في 20 22
مايو فاقم الضغط على البلدان الاكثر فقرا
والتي شحت على الارجح كميات الغذاء فيها
وهي اقل بكثير
على كل المزيد معنا من عمان سفير الامم
المتحده للاغذيه والزراعه سابقا وخبير
الامن الغذاء الدكتور فاضل الزعبي اهلا بك
دكتور فاضل همم اسمح لي ان اسالك بدايه
الى ماذا تميل اكثر هل تميل الى ان نحتفل
كما يرى غوترس ام الى الفزع كما تحدث
الفاو
والله حقيقه اميل الى الحذر والخوف
لان المعادله عكسيه جدا مع ازدياد عدد
السكان سوف يزداد الحاجه الى الغذاء
والمعادله العكسيه تكون في انهار وتدهور
نوعيه التربه والاراضي يزداد تغيرات
المناخيه اثرت على الموارد الطبيعيه كامله
وخاصه وجود المياه همم التغيرات المناخيه
وازدياد درجه الحراره يؤثر على الانتاج
الزراعي سواء النباتي او حتى الحيواني
وهذا كله مما يزيد الفجوه فجوه انعدام من
امن الغذائي وهذا مصدر القلق الذي يدعونا
الى ان نستذكر بان المجتمع الدولي كان او
العالم العالم لم يكن على قدر المسؤوليه
في مواجهه الصدمات السابقه سواء صدمه
اوكرانيا وحتى الصدمه همم كورونا لذلك
هنالك التخوف نعم
يتعلق بالمشاكل التي توا احنا غذائيا هي
المشكله في الطاقه الاستيعابيه اذا ما صحت
تعبير للارض ام انه يجب ان نحمل المسؤوليه
كامله همم لنا اشخاص
الجهتين خليني اجي على الطاقه الاستيعابيه
للارض همم لم يتم اعتماد نظم الغذاء
المستدامه الجديده التي تقوم على استخدام
التكنولوجيا وبالتالي تزيد من انتاجيه
وحده المساحه وتزيد من انتاجيه وحده
المياه التي سوف تمكننا بالمصادر الموجوده
لدينا وبالاراضي الموجوده لدينا مع زياده
السكان ان التغلب على هذه الفجوه والنقطه
الاخرى نحن همم افراد وكدول مازلنا لم نصل
الى مستوى التحدي يعني خليني اذكر نقطه
ثانويه ولو اني باعتبرها اساسيه
الفاقد والمهدر من الغذاء عندما يصل الى
اكثر من الثلث هذا دليل بان همم لسنا
مسؤولين امام همم التعامل مع فجوه الغذاء
بجدي اكثر فما بالك اذا ازداد عدد السكان
وتغير الانماط الاستهلاك اذا اذا اذا
اصبحنا جديين دكتور هل فات الاوان او لم
يفوت هل القادرين على اعاده ساعه الى
الوراء اذا ما صح التعبير
همم
الكثير من الخطوات التي بامكاننا ان نبدا
بها همم اذا ما ذكرنا زياد عدد السكان
وتغيرات مناخيه والضغط الذي سيواجهه كميات
همم توفر او ما يتوفر من الغذاء حتما
استخدام التكنولوجيا الحديثه في الزراعه
استخدام التكنولوجيات التي تؤدي الى توفير
هذه المواد
زياده عدد السكان طبيعيه ومباركه او لا
عندنا مشكله بهذا الاطار
يعني ايضا يصبح النمو الاقتصادي موازي لما
همم لنسبه الزياده السكانيه فهي عده عوامل
بس هي يعني بالنهايه هي مباركه
الانسان بدا يعيش اكثر
فيجب ان يكون جديان اكثر والفاول لما رفعت
ناقوس ودقت ناقوس الخطر بهذا الاتجاه لم
يكن الهدف منه تقليد سكان وانما تنبيه
المجتمع الدولي الى ضروره العمل بجديه
اكثر
لمواكبه هذا الحدث
كل عمال مشترك بالنهايه هل ترى في ظل
تطورات انت ذكرت اوكرانيا وروسيا ما يحدث
الان من تطورات هل من امل تعتقد ان يكون
في عمل مشترك بهذا الاطار
هنالك طبعا معوقات اهمها وتحديات اهم
الاطراف المتحاربه للغذاء كاسلاح سلاح
سياسي سلاح عسكري وهذا يؤثر على وضع الامن
الغذائي لكن في النهايه في النهايه همم
لابد من التعاون لانه لا يستطيع المجتمع
الدولي ان يعيش همم معادلات منقوصه يتحكم
بها السلاح حتى كل الاطراف
لشروط
الطلب والعرض والحاجه في العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك
الى الموجز موجز الخامسه الرياضي مع زياد
زياد
شكرا يا ميسون واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
تعرض اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو ورونالدو
الى رده فعل غير متوقع من مواطنه وزميله
في مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزيه برونو
فرناندوز خلال معسكر المنتخب استعدادا
لبطوله كاس العالم ودخل برونو فرنانديز
الى غرفه الملابس متجاه الى رونالدو وسلم
عليه بطريقه باهته اظهرت تعبيرات مدهشه
على وجه رونالدو ما دفع الصحافه
البريطانيه لربط الموقف بتصريحات رونالدو
الاخيره اتجاه نادي
ابدا اللاعب الارجنتيني ميسي حضره بشان
امال منتخب بلاده بالفوز بلقب بطوله الكاس
العالم المقبله واشار ميسي في حديث اجراه
مع اتحاد امريكا الجنوبيه لكره القدم الى
ان الجميع متحمس للمشاركه في المونديال
لكننا نفكر بالسير خطوه بخطوه ونعلم ان
مجموعتك كاس العالم ليست سهله وتلعب
الارجنتين وديا غدا مع منتخب الامارات في
العاصمه الاماراتيه ابو ظبي
في اسبانيا قال كوكي لاعب منتخب اسبانيا
ان خلوها المنتخب المشارك في المونديال
مينا النجوم لن يحد من فرصته بالفوز
باللقب مؤكدا ان القوه الجماعيه للفريق
اكثر اهميه من المواهب الفرديه للاعبين
وذلك في مؤتمر الصحفي عقده المنتخب في مقر
التدريبيه بالعاصمه مدريد ويخوض بطل
العالم السابق مباراته الاولى في
المونديال في الثالث والعشرين من شهر
الحالي امامه منتخب كوستاريكا
من جانبه يرشح النرويجي ايرلندا هلنت لاعب
نادي مانشستر سيتي الانجليزيه منتخبات
البرازيل الارجنتين وفرنسا للفوز بلقب
مونديال قطر بالاضافه الى انجلترا بدرجه
اقل واقال هلنت بانه سيستغل عطله منتصف
الموسم للاستجمام والتعافي بعد بدايته
المثيره في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز لكره
القدم
البرازيل حصه تدريبيه في مدينه تورينو
الايطاليه قبل توجه الى العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه للمشاركه في المونديال ضمن
المجموعه السابعه ويستهلال المنتخب
البرازيلي مشواره بمواجهه الصربي في
الرابع والعشرين من الشهر الحالي وسبق
للمنتخبين ان نلتقي يا مره واحده في كاس
العالم وكان في دوري المجموعات من مونديال
روسيا وانتهت بفوزها البرازيل بهدفين دون
مقابل وتضمن المجموعه السابعه ايضا
المنتخبه سويسرا والكاميرون
وقد المدرب دراجان السايكوفيتش اخر تدريب
للمنتخب الصربي قبل التوجه الى قطر واثناء
المدرب على اللاعبين مضيفا انهم ذاهبون
للمنافسه باعصاب هادئه على الرغم من ان
المجموعه هي الاصعب بين المجموعات وتلعب
صربيا في المجموعه السابعه الى جانب
منتخبات البرازيل الكاميرون وكذلك المنتخب
السويسريه
وتواصل تحضيرات المنتخب البلجيكي في بلاده
قبل ايام من انطلاق منافسات كاس العالم
وستواجه بلجيكا منتخب مصر وديا في الكويت
يوم الجمعه المقبل وتشارك بلجيكا في
المجموعه السادسه الى جانب كندا والمغرب
وكذلك المنتخب الكرواتيا
يلتقي منتخب المانيا مع نظيره العماني غدا
الاربعاء في استاد مجمع السلطان قابوس في
مسقط في مباراه الوديه هي الثانيه بينهما
بعد الاولى التي اقيمت قبل 24 عاما وستكون
المحطه الاخيره للفريق الالماني قبل
التوجه الى الدوحه لخوض منافسات كاس
العالم وتبدا المانيا مشوارها ضد اليابان
في الثالث 23 من شهر الحالي ضمن منافسات
المجموعه الخامسه لبطوله كاس العالم
في ختامي تحضيراته لبطوله كاس العالم
المقبله يلتقي المنتخب السعودي غدا مع
منتخب كرواتيا على ملعب الامير فيصل بن
فهد في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض المباراه
هي الوديه الاولى بين المنتخب السعودي في
كاس العالم للمره السادسه وتلعب امام
الارجنتين في اول مباراه لها في المونديال
الثلاثاء المقبل ضمن منافسات المجموعه
الثالثه التي تضم ايضا المكسيك وكذلك
المنتخب البولندي
شهدت قوائم المنتخبات المشاركه في بطوله
كاس العالم تواجدت 9 لاعبين من الدوري
السعودي لكره القدم دعونا وتابع
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك من سوريا
الان حيث اعتقلت اجهزه الامن المزيد من
المشتبه بهم في تنفيذ تفجير اسطنبول يصل
العدد الى 50 على الاقل في وقت اظهر فيديو
جديد احلام البشير طبعا هي الفتاه السوريه
التي زرعت عبوه ناسفه في الشارع الاستقلال
في اسطنبول اظهرها تركض ومسرعه قبل انفجار
العبوه بدقائق قليلا
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عزاء
الحزب الجمهوري في الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه فوزه باضافه خمسه مقاعد جديده
في سباق نحو السيطره على مجلس النواب
الامريكي ليصبح على بعد مقعد واحد فقط من
تحقيق الاغلبيه ارتفع عدد مقاعد الحزب
الجمهوري الى 217 مقعد مقابل 205
للديمقراطيين فيما يتبقى 13 مقعدا لم يتم
حسمهما حتى الان
الديمقراطيه كيتي هوبس منصب حاكم ولايه
اريزونا بعد التغلب على منى فيستاتها
الجمهوريه المدعومه من الرئيس السابق
ترامب كيرليك كما حسم الحسبه الديمقراطيه
سباق الاغلبيه بمجلس الشيوخ بعد فوز
المرشح ماركيلي على منى فسيل جمهوري
ماسترز وبذلك استحوذ الحسبه الجمهوري على
50 مقعدا بمجلس الشيوخ مقابل 49
ويتواصل الجدل الذي يثيره الملياردير الى
الماسك منذ استحوا هذه على منصه تويتر
للتواصل الاجتماعي عمل جديد فقط طرد
الملياردير موظف في المنصف عبر تغريده
مباشره
بعد الحكومه الصينيه الى الالتزام الصارم
بسياسه صفر كوفيد المتشدده في محاوله
لتوجيه الراي العام بعد تخفيف القيود في
بعض الاماكن شددت وسائل الاعلام محليه
حكوميه على ضروره الالتزام بالسياسه التي
تتطلب اختبارات الزاميه جماعيه ووضع
الملايين تحت الاغلاق في محاوله للقضاء
على فيروس كورونا
الخامس انتهت شكرا المتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا